si les ménages que daniel auteuil
bonsoir alors sans dévoiler le film et
pour mieux le cadre est peut-être
d'écouter sans rapide une sorte de
lexique nécessaires d'abord le titre du
film
la veuve de saint-pierre c'est la
guillotine et puis c'est bon c'est ça
sera prêt à la fin la veuve de
saint-pierre effectivement belle a
répondu c'est laglio sonatine que l'on
attend dans le film un point de
géographie saint pierre saint pierre et
miquelon donc une île perdue vers 9
au loin du canada
du nord du nord du canada avant le film
la réponse est là thermique look est
donc une toute petit archipel au milieu
de l'océan qui vit donc repliée sur elle
même dans cette bonne société qui elle
même vieilli dans une sorte d'exil forcé
il est vrai que c'est un peu un fait
divers qui le point de départ de ce
scénario oui parce que neil est un
personnage qui a réellement existé et
qui a été condamné à mort dans cette
petit archipel et mais il n'y avait pas
de voeux dans toute la question est de
savoir est ce qu'on va pouvoir trouver
une veuve ou pas et elle va tout faire
pour défendre cet homme parce que pour
elle tout redemption est possible on
peut renaître de ses cendres et son mari
qui est le complice ont son premier
complice validé dans ce parcours
alors encore un point de précision ce
rôle que vous interprétez
merveilleusement je dirais avec lumières
comme souvent la veuve on appelle à la
veuve elle deviendra s'en va pas tout
raconter madame la madame là c'était un
symbole c'est une grande chance madame
la capitaine puisqu'elle c'est la femme
du capitaine mais pour moi c'était mme
adam blythe il présente prête à l'action
a retroussé ses manches à y aller c'est
un c'est une façon de je sais pas c'est
une invention de claude serra do qui est
le scénariste
alors vous avez vous avez tourné dans
des conditions de froid extrême
j'ai eu surtout le sentiment que le
froid était une sorte de partenaires
presque un allié en tout cas un
ingrédient de la façon dont vous avez
construit votre votre personnage que
c'est une façon de tous nous réunir très
fort combien par mois 25 à 30 degrés oui
on a démarré juste qu'un jour un peu
quand même remettre les choses en face
et on n'a pas tourné pendant cinq mois
dans le grand froid on a démarré comme
ça puis après c'est vrai que ça ça ne
vit ça nous lie et puis quand on va
tourner après dans les studios c'est
bien d'avoir en mémoire quand même cette
idée de que la vie est rude mais en
votre personnage est très envie touche
les traits corsetée qui en même temps
tellement loin des conventions une femme
extrêmement libre pas du tout on peut
justement d'en face il est résistante à
sa façon une famille résistante
c'est vrai que les kilos sur le dos avec
parce que c'est mon tout de fourrure et
compagnie c'est et ses 30 kilos et avec
votre défaut il faut marcher avec ça et
je crois que finalement les points de
départ en tout cas pour mon personnage
soit avait juste une couverture c'est
peut-être lié mais cela va aider à
rentrer chaud au coeur parce que c'était
une histoire lors votre personnage du
capitaine j'ai envie de dire que c'est
vraiment l'amour extrême l'amour fou
l'amour total
oui un nouveau talent mais amour partagé
et puis aussi amour amour adultes quoi
c'est à dire que que c'est cet homme
effectivement au delà de toute
convention de toute morale thaler
j'écoutais dans le reportage
adhap disait que le capitaine trouvé ça
oui il suivait plus par amour que par
conviction mais
il est aussi convaincu quelques l'homme
qui a été condamnée jugé au début sera
pas le même guillotiné à la fin quoi
donc
c'est la force de ce couple d'un dépôt
mais c'est que ils luttent ensemble à ce
titre est un couple très extrêmement de
moderne mais ce que merveilleux ce qui
laisse faire il la regarde il va
jusqu'au bout jusque là où votre
personnage vous emmène sachant qu'il va
sa perdition
et puis à ces moments très chauds très
charnelle il prend ses affaires il est
derrière son odeur il est derrière elle
dansait partout d'associer normand henry
passionnément amoureux de sa femme c'est
un amour rassure moi réciproque et c'est
au delà de
elle c'est au delà de 2,2 de toute
morale c'est à dire que les gens de de
saint-pierre vont penser mesquinement un
triangle à une histoire soleil c'est ça
alors ce qui est vrai dans le film j'ai
envie de dire qu'il ya une charge contre
à la fois les conventions la médiocrité
la bêtise de la bonne société bourgeoise
c'est une charge aussi contre la peine
de mort
même si c'est pas au fond un film à
thèse non je crois qu'elle est là elle a
un besoin de de sortir de ce de ces lois
justement qui sont faites par les hommes
est ce que c'est
sont les hommes qui font les lois ou
est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on peut les
remettre en question qu'est-ce qui fait
évoluer une loi est ce qu est ce qu on a
le droit et je crois qu'elle n'a pas
peur elle n'a pas peur jusqu'au moment
où elle voit que que le danger est là et
qu'elle va peut-être perdre son mari
alors j'ai envie de dire que je suis pas
du tout étonnée vous ayez eu envie de
jouer ce rôle là peut-être me trompe
mais je trouve que c'est un personnage
danse positive avec cette idée de la
rédemption
alors est ce que vous pensez vous qu'à
chaque fois que vous faites un film il
faut comme gravir une marche un échelon
supérieur que c'était le cas dans sud
alors l'échelon supérieur je sais pas où
est ce qu'il est en tout cas
c'était quand j'ai lu l'histoire pour
moi c'était un film que je devais
raconter c'était une histoire que je
devais que je devais sortir à travers
moi à l'intérieur de moi et de partager
ça pour moi c'était la conviction dès le
départ et puis ensuite quand on est
monté à cheval daniel sur le sur cette
idée de tourner ce film tout de suite
bien il a envie de galoper avoir fait
c'est la première fois que vous jouez en
tout cas ensemble avec quelques presque
rendez vous raté j'ai envie de dire mais
cette fois ci ça y est qu'est-ce que
vous avez découvert là sur l'autre qui
est peut-être vous a surpris
dans votre façon de travailler toute
façon de jouer non mais je crois qu'il
écoute qu'on à l'un de l'autre
ça fait ça fait je crois la une des
forces du film en tout cas parce que
comme disait patrice dans le reportage
le on sent plus que ce qu'il ya derrière
plus que ce qui est dit en quoi elles
vous ressemble cette femme madame là où
il ya beaucoup de moi et puis à la fois
jeu on n'a pas les mêmes origines je
suis dit oui une grande bourgeoise pour
la même chose
en quoi ce qu'elle me ressemble c'est
que c'est que les choses peuvent être
remises en question et que et qu'il faut
savoir les poser sur la table et puis
pas avoir peur de ces de ce qu'on pense
vous daniel ton amour ils vous
ressemblent ce personnage facile à dire
il ya toujours il ya toujours une part
de soi la partie cachée de l'iceberg qui
qui est dans les tous les personnages
qu'on peut jouer bien sûr il ya
forcément une partie de mes connivence
et bien sûr merci à tous c'est la fin de
ce journal